he's here in LA to launch the SiriusXM
Hollywood studios his third bestseller
is Howard Stern comes again the king
[Applause]
thank you
very excited you know what it is I'm
never in Los Angeles
so it seems very exciting when I am here
back in New York no one pays its really
because I'm listening to eat Alaska
listen you're all the time and you're a
lot of anxiety just about hacking I had
so much anxiety it's not Vietnam in the
60s you know ass Angela for me it is i
mean yeah yeah it's like I don't like to
travel I like the comfort of my own home
studio but I have to say it was kind of
fun coming out here you know with weed
being legal I don't smoke weed but
everyone is very quiet it's very nice
but I know you you know you love your
home and you love your quiet studio but
come on the one thing you don't get and
don't tell me you don't like it is that
I like this but when I'm working and I'm
you know because I wrote this book you
know part of the thing that I like about
doing these interviews is that there is
no audience that the audience it's quiet
in the studio you forget that you're on
the radio and a lot of truth comes out
you were a guest on my show and I
thought that you were amazing and I
thought we had this great discussion
about your career in comedy everything a
90 minutes it went it went 90 and it was
that's what I love about satellite radio
yeah the faculty not a lot of people
could do it nah you do it well you you
get people to be confess Oriole why well
I think it's because I'm genuinely
interested and I I'm inquisitive I have
a lot of questions and I often say this
I and I think I told you this that I got
involved in psychotherapy and I really
enjoyed the process of sitting there and
being listened to and I thought well if
I if my guests could really be listened
to and really be heard it might be a
really nice experience and because I was
on satellite radio and we had so much
time that I could sit there with someone
and not cut them off but give them an
opportunity to really express themselves
and I ended up with this great
collection of interviews with some of my
heroes you know it's really - it's a
terrific book thank you
now that we've plugged it right in
thanks Oliver I swear to you that's why
I came out to LA the publisher said you
don't be great if you got out there now
it's your book for Christmas of your
word and I did it you said to me at
Jerry Seinfeld's birthday party you said
I will do your show and that's rare you
don't do a lot of shows so I appreciate
it I don't you know what's weird thank
you but you know what's weird about this
show I've been sitting in my hotel room
all day obsessing about it because it's
it's a weird time out here in LA in
terms of the actual time that you go
live 7:00 and I found that yeah I go to
bed at 8 o'clock and I'm like a big baby
so I'm like a wolf I read up I was like
should I should I eat dinner before I
come to Bill's show or not and what
would i I mean these were big decisions
right and then I was actually going to
be very LA and go to the pool and hang
out and I went now if I do that my hair
won't dry in time and I do want to look
my best for this show so there you go
there was my date I'm happy to be and
I'm very happy that we got to be friends
again because I swear to God
yeah it's true I swear to God when I
listen to you I think there's only two
sane people left in America and it's me
and this guy I'm listening to oh I swear
to God because we I invariably agree
with you on everything everything that
comes up well I felt awful that we
weren't talking for so long because I'm
such a fan of this show and I think this
show is so necessary right now
[Applause]
I I really am shocked I know I know you
probably don't care about winning an
Emmy and I know you've been nominated
but you've never actually won 40 times
is it really 40 times 40 times give the
man an Emmy all right many guys are
working live but this gets about
something else we have in common
yes why I don't win that Emmy we're
honest people you don't like honesty
they say they do the fans do but why why
if if Hollywood is such a liberal town
you would think Hollywood because that's
why you and I are the last sane people
cuz we're liberals but we don't go for
all the [ __ ] Bartlett's right right
right
and maybe that I don't know what it and
that's not good enough for the Liberals
who vote at the academy so you think
that the Academy is that
well-thought-out and they're conspiring
against you
look I really do think you deserve a
nice but you know what winning that's
for losers that's right but it's
interesting because you know we do have
this other parallel I mean I moved here
in 2003 I moved to serious to after s
triol in 2005 greatest thing that ever
happened to me - yeah we wrote these
second acts yes right in places for me
and and for you it's true when the
United States government decided to go
after me you know
the censorship the religious right it
really was mind-boggling because the
stations that I work for were being
fined it was a form of racketeering by
the United States government they were
venting these companies that hired me to
do further business so I was really
boxed in I felt my show was being edited
to death there really it was just
debilitating so moving to satellite
radio was a godsend and really it just
freed me to do what I really wanted so
you know for me the show has never been
better and and in terms of my life I
just feel a lot more relaxed well
because again like we are what Frank
Sinatra would have said was in the
autumn of our years yes I know I know
it's very depressing we've taught the
way not a wrinkle on your face is that
right that's
[Applause]
you're the one who puts that [ __ ] on
your hands get to that later by just 15
times that's that's horrible we have to
I know I got to go to Vegas right after
this show I know you wouldn't stay
anyway but we have to talk about health
off stage sometime yes you have some
shitty ideas about it okay about health
yes you do what are you talking I'm not
gonna talk about it here I want to talk
about many other things we have living
you know on my Metamucil right now okay
you have no idea how that changed my
life when my doctor told me to go I met
him you so I was like that's for old
people I don't do change my life Toto
toilet okay well it I know I know you're
talking okay all right but what's so
amazing is that when I hear you talk
about so many things I wrote you this
note about when you're talking about
show tunes in your house yes
I'm like oh my god you think you heard
my boy bill a lot oh my god my parents
play damn Yankee we all we all had the
same boomers we all had the same
childhood and yet as you point out the
one big difference between us is I am in
a committed loving relationship by the
way I work with Bill Maher's father yes
when I worked at NBC radio right a
fabulous guy there's no you know this is
so rushed I should really have the whole
hour to myself yeah
to say the thing we really should get
into we really should get into this I
don't understand like I don't even see
you why are you leaning into me for this
[Applause]
you're a heterosexual male immense
annoyed is it do you ever have like a
serious girlfriend we're four because we
don't see you okay first of all this is
my interview more time but let's their
you alive some people might say when
you're married you're not alive that's
you people are so personal about this
issue no no no I just we don't just
judge you're not better or I'm not worse
because we have different you have a
girlfriend I don't need a girlfriend you
don't you don't need one not in the
traditional sense depends on what you
mean by girlfriend is there someone that
maybe you hang out with that you adore
and makes you feel good yes but it's fun
but it's not one person and that's where
we're different you're so angry I'm not
you're taking over my job you know
see you don't know how to go ahead you
asked me a question
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why are you so [ __ ] up no that's
that's gonna take more than a minute oh
I know yeah why I mean you're in therapy
I don't get that and you've been in
therapy I already changed my life I know
what you said 25 years yeah 25 years to
me that's a scam either you know don't
really won't even put that out there in
my book I can explain why we're so
important my life it made me a better
father made me a better human being when
do you don't be happy when you're cured
I you know what I don't know that I'm
cured but I need someone to talk to who
can talk everyday to stop it you know
come again but took a mental health if I
could say the woman thing I heard you
would do me more this week yes Jennifer
Anniston you've said this to you because
your mother was depressed and you took
it upon yourself to cheer her up
yes you have this Savior complex with
women your captain save-a-ho you're
right my mother my mother was profoundly
said my mother lost her mother when she
was nine years old and and being raised
by a woman who had no mother in a sense
needed a parent right and yeah I did
spend a lot of time with my mother
trying to cheer her up and trying to
make her happy and I didn't want to see
her sad and I think that has carried
over in my adult life my relationships
with women I kind of look for someone
and I tried I try to be all things and
be you know a hero and all of that stuff
and that's not healthy and that's one of
the reasons I went into therapy and I
think my relationship with my wife now
he's a lot more even-keeled because I'm
not sitting there trying to save it I
mean except from me bita you know
imagine me crawling on top of you
it's not a look like it was about to
happen
yeah I mean when you got divorced I
remember a lot of people said you know
what saved Howard because that was back
when you were an [ __ ] and I told you
on your show I was Nestle - I just
wasn't an [ __ ] to you I was an
[ __ ] to you and I yeah I know and I
appreciate it and I probably do I love
the guy and by the way one of the great
things about being this age even though
we are older and the bad thing is we'll
be dead sooner right the fact that when
we were young not just you
somebody feuds and fights when you get
to this age
it all seems stupid but making up but
that's always therapy really is a good I
didn't need it I got but I was it but
okay that's you but I was at war with
the world I was a guy who was very angry
and I was angry if anybody had a
listener or an audience that wasn't mine
right so I was competing with everyone
right and it led to a lot of friendships
that broke up right so in any case
that's another reason that therapy was
good for me not for you because you're
perfect right no no he is perfect the 17
women he's dating and he's he's
wonderful
thrilled with you okay it's personal
some people need therapy and marriage
and some people don't about these women
that you can it's not my show with all
seventies my questions did its my
question yes my question just seventeen
summit stop it fourteen give us another
where do you hide that stop it so when
you got divorced a lot of people said
you know the reason why Howard was able
to be an [ __ ] is because his saving
grace was he loved his wife and in
America is nothing good at you can do
than to love your wife so it's like we
forgive him for all the [ __ ] stuff
now that he divorced right he's gonna
lose that the fans never left not know
they did it and you know what it's such
a good lesson but you know my fans are
very loyal to me and I think the reason
they give you and I think the reason
seriously that they didn't leave is that
I was upfront and honest with them yeah
and I never could I never tried to
present myself like the religious right
does oh you know we have the perfect
relationships and marriages forever and
this and that I didn't lie about that
kind of stuff and you know when you
present yourself as holier-than-thou
then people call you a hypocrite right
if you say look I'm human and not
everything works out I think people are
willing to well absolutely and the thing
that I love that your aren't most honest
about that no one's honest about
jealousy it's a theme in your show yes
you know you always say it when you are
jealous and I'm jealous all the time
right and I'm jealous of things you have
not not the personal stuff right I'm
jealous that you know you you get away
with [ __ ] I can't get away with and that
always your why is that because first of
all you don't have a politically correct
audience this is a good audience but I
sometimes have to fight my way through
that [ __ ] by the way one of the
things one of the things when I
interview a billable support when you
talk you only have Robin who's awesome
right and that's
because that's the advantage I am such a
recluse and seriously shy I know that
going into radio for me as a young man
was perfect I would sit in these booths
by myself in the beginning and I
wouldn't have to look at an audience and
it was fabulous because who wants to
look at an audience I just would imagine
one guy in his car and that's who I was
broadcasting and you you know and and
quite honestly you said to me in the
interview as much as you love your
audience you also would you fantasize
about not having these people here and
you can all leave right now getting
better they're getting better they're
behaving better well we're trying to
bothers you to have the live audiences
what bothers me to not be able to say
the thing I want to say that they really
agree with but because they're out in
public they have to be oh we're good
people we can't laugh at that or we have
to groan to show that we're yes and that
[ __ ] pisses me off
and by the way as a broadcaster as one
broadcaster to another I have to tell
you it is very liberating
I'm not sitting there be it isn't right
it's only my own fantasy mix but I
listened to you last week in you at an
Arnold Schwarzenegger impersonator it's
fast and he did 20 minutes on Robin I
got to come on your kids jerking off
right now
I'm smudging all over you and then I
listen the other day and you have a
special guest and I hear Arnold
Schwarzenegger is voice nothing oh it's
another Arnold Schwarzenegger in person
it's the real one it was so great to
have my brother there because at one
point I turned to Arnold you know the
real Arnold and I said governor be
honest with us I need you to tell me the
truth
what's gonna happen when we die now most
people if you said that would say how
the heck would I know I don't know he
goes what is going to happen to you if
we're gonna lay there dead and nothing
is gonna be there's gonna be no heaven
there's not gonna be anything you're
just gonna lay there and rot then I said
that is a fantastic answer yeah what I
know
I got a real what do you think I do I
got into the plan to talk to these
people
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you